I am eco Weiss I'm here for my
alternative this is my favorite action
scene
I love that scene because you know it's
really violence it's really aggressive
like maybe like more than five people
against one people and like it's really
rough really greedy and aggressive so
when I when I see the corrector was like
really you know it's really brutal but
it's not like curricula but real a lot
of impact a lot of you know like a
weapon landing on his body it's really
brilliant and like sound as well every
single angle shot is like really well
that Tweety in 1967 it's really complex
I mean truly smart choreography as well
and really it's really great because I
believe that every angle every every
single angle it's brilliant when
Jackie's fight with Benny it's like the
Kirov is really intense as well so I
learned a lot about about Jackie dance
scene like ending scene is like
brilliant
it's challenge because you know it's
like it's different when a man hit the
girl I mean like so you had to be more
control you know so because the power
power from the man and land to the
girl's body and I did in trade too but
you know it's feel really bad for me but
when I when I watch Jackie Jackie Chan
movie in America it's like brilliant
because they trust each other they
professional and they they are brilliant
I like the scene at the ending scene you
know I know the director when she kicked
the Hat it's really more powerful and
suddenly the the fighter was like Kanaka
like immediately because you know the
the the fighter was the director